This is great.
Now you have your record audio
function executing every time
the user presses
the record audio button.
This is an example of going
from user interface element,
in this case the record button,
to your code using an IP action.
What about going to the other way,
from code to user interface element?
Maybe we want to enable or
disable a button,
or we want to change
the text of a label.
When you go from code to UI element, you
use a connection called an IB outlet,
otherwise known as an outlet
from code to UI element.
Let's add that one of those in.
To start with,
let's open back the inspector's panel
by clicking this button
here on the top right.
Make sure that library's
selected here on the right.
In addition, for a moment, I'm going to
come out of the assistant editor
just to give me more screen real estate.
There we go.
Now I can see my interface.
I'm going to drag over a label and
a button.
To start with,
I'm going to search for a label.
Found the one.
I'm going to drag one here.
And I'm going to name
this label Tap to Record.
And I'm going to reposition
it back in the middle.
And then, I'm going to search for
a button.
I'm going to drag
another button on here.
Try to center it as best as I
can in the center of the screen.
Double-click inside, and type in
Stop Recording for the button's text.
Don't worry about the layout yet.
We're going to tackle
that in just a bit.
Now, pay attention,
because here comes the unintuitive part.
We want to make a connection
from code to UI element,
in this case the Tap to Record lable.
>From the document outline,
find our Tap to Record label
as you can see highlight here.
Hold down the Ctrl key, and
drag it into our ViewController class.
Select outlet, and
name this recording label.
You can now see Xcode's
created an outlet for
us linking the UI element into code,
or, as we're going to use it,
an outlet from code,
where we can change the UI element.
Let's use this IB outlet.
Let's make the text change after
the record button has been pressed.
So, what we want here is we want
the text of the recording label
to change when the record
button is pressed.
You already know which code gets called
when the recording button is pressed,
that's the function we wrote earlier
as an IB action, right here.
We can add the following line
to the recordAudio function.
If you run the app now, and
press on the Record audio button,
you should be able to see the text
change to Recording in progress.
We can see that our label and
button are not positioned correctly.
That's okay.
If we press this button,
we should see this change from Tap to
Record into Recording in progress.
So, we've used an IB action to receive
an interaction, even on a button.
And then, we used an IB outlet to
reach back from code to UI element,
in this case, the label and
change this text.